now as a planets our use of oil will
peak in the 2030s that's a view of BP
which expect current demand will
probably rise by another 10% before
leveling off with population growth and
increased consumption by emerging
economies that means increased
efficiency and electric vehicles will
play a big part and cutting down our use
of plastics will help to be peace chief
economist spencer deo explained the
company's thinking to me earlier oil is
very heavily concentrated within the
transport sector the world will carry on
and traveling and transporting goods and
services and people more and more we
think demand for transport services B in
terms of people or in terms of Freight
what will more than double over the next
25 years
but those planes trains and automobiles
we use to do that transportation will be
get increasingly efficient over time and
so the growth in any of aldermont will
gradually slow and then sort of stop
growing we think in one particular
scenario towards the end of the 2030 and
within that big big rise in renewables
which you say has even caught BP out in
terms of the by the strength of it yes
so we expect renewable energy wind and
solar in particular to grow
extraordinary strongly over the next 25
years accounting for around 40% of the
growth of all energy will be in that
renewable space so that's a really
significant amount and yes and BP and I
think pretty much along with Morris all
other forecasters have been surprised
just by the strength of the of the
growth in wind power but particularly
solar power some of that is
technological gain just the pace at
which some of these improvements have
been made I have a BP significant but
also a significant role here is the
degree of government support
particularly in countries like China and
India where that governments of Paul has
pushed through the penetration more
quickly than we thought and those two
things end up being reinforcing each
other because as more and more wind and
solar energy is generated you get better
at doing it you move down your learning
curve and those and costs come down so
that they reinforce each people be quite
surprised that whilst you see demand for
coal plateauing it's still going to be a
very big contributor to global energy
supplies by the middle of the century
yeah so we sort of have coal flatlining
over the next 25 years and that's an a
remarkable change if you look back at
over the last 10 or 15 years coal has
been the dominant source of energy
growth over much of that period
particularly because of it was the coal
it was a fuel which fueled the massive
rapid industrialization of China but
what we're seeing is particularly in
China a shift to a more sustainable
pattern of energy growth slower growth
less energy intensive growth less cold
intensive growth so we see coal
consumption in China falling in outright
terms I think it's increasingly likely
that coal consumption in China has now P
the other really interesting thing in
this report though is that the pitcher
is for the internal combustion engine
shouldn't be written quite yet I mean
even by 2040 you think eighty-five
percent of all cars will still be
traditional petrol diesel engines yeah
so on one side electric cars are
happening and they're going to grow
enormous Lee quickly in a particular
scenario you are talking about they go
from something like 3 million electric
cars on the planet today to 300 million
electric cars on the planet but by of
2040 so that's happening it's real but
we also think the number of total cars
on the planet will double from about a
billion today to about 2 billion and by
2040 now this point you may be thinking
if I goodness I don't need and that more
than twice as many cars on the streets
of London this is not happening in
London the vast majority of this growth
of cars and the number cars and car
travel is happening in fast-growing
developing economies China India where
hundreds of millions of families can buy
that therefore their first motor car for
the first time afford to buy their car
for the first time we also highlights
the growing opposition to single-use
plastic and packaging and do you think
that's going to eat into oil demand as
well yes an important sort of feature of
all demand growth going forward is the
use of oil not as a source of energy but
rather as a feedstock particularly to
petrochemicals so to make plastics
paints fibers polyester suits and so on
and now not all of oil and we
which is non combusted is used for
plastics and not all plastics about
plastics I look round this to do much of
this is made of plastic and there's
nothing wrong with that
but what we do think is in increasing
environmental concerns about sort of
single-use plastics and packaging
plastic bags an obvious one plastic
straws another one and we think that
environmental concerns will lead to a
slower growth in in in that type of use
of oil than we've seen in the past and
and that's likely to dampen growth
relative to all past trends may offset
before joining BP you were chief
economist at the Bank of England I can't
resist asking you what would you be
voting for if you are still on the
monetary policy committee you know one
of the most pleasurable things about
this job moving to be peers I don't I
genuinely don't think about UK interest
rates and anymore